this is not the video you think it is so
whatever you're doing with that dislike
button right now chill out because if
the comment section under this video or
the twitter mentions i've received for
this video might suggest this is far
more complicated than the title alone
suggests and i agree dragon ball across
its almost 40 years of publication and
or release has seen enormous success
revolutionizing the industry and
influencing the hearts and minds of
multiple generations across its four
separate decades its most recent films
have done tremendously well in the box
office and to this day retains a massive
fan base the likes of which any ip would
yearn to possess but
the story doesn't resonate with me the
way it once did
while myself and many people still very
much enjoyed the story for what it is
these days there's something
fundamentally different about this story
i love and grew up with and i'm not the
only one that feels this way so what
happened well first of all i want to say
that this video is not trying to point
out that dragon ball super or any part
of the modern dragon ball material is
necessarily bad and on the flip side
this video isn't suggesting that older
fans are stuck in the past either
gatekeeping sucks and this video exists
in an attempt to explain why there's a
large population of people yearning for
what was rather than discredit those who
enjoy it as it is and so at the
forefront of this video i ask for your
time your patience and your
understanding as i explore and examine
the series we all love to try and
pinpoint the exact day
dragon ball died for so
[Music]
many so what does it mean when a show
dies this hyperbolic title is on the top
of many videos a lot of them quite
antagonistic and many of them analytical
but they're all interested in one thing
pinpointing where a series made a change
when big enough to fracture an audience
the simpsons is a very popular and
uncontroversial example of this referred
to by the community as the zombification
of the simpsons following a massive
exodus of the original running staff
during season six the show itself
gradually changed from a counterculture
critique of the status quo to eventually
and ironically becoming the very thing
it was a parody of and it's not just the
simpsons either plenty of other series
across the decades have fallen to this
very common phenomenon shows like the us
office family guy game of thrones and
community for many individuals featured
a change in approach due to divisive
creative decisions a transfer of
creative power fan fatigue and sometimes
cast exodus and as inflammatory as it
might sound to liken dragon ball to some
of these more extreme examples the main
reason i chose this video format in the
first place wasn't simply to point out
that i think this show is dead but to
speak about a very specific aspect that
no other series i could find offers put
simply i believe there is a specific day
in which dragon ball as it was once
known died despite its long-staying
success imagine if you will a show like
the simpsons changing dramatically but
still remaining critically successful
within its existing fan base well that's
dragon ball and so i want to tackle this
in two sections the first being when did
dragon ball die and the second why did
it die
so let's start by asking the first
question
when did dragon ball die
change isn't something that's new to
dragon ball foundational aspects of the
story have changed time and again even
within the original pre-dragon ball z
section of the series transforming
itself from an episodic style gag comic
focused on adventure and comedy in the
first arc eventually it switched his
focus to battle and martial arts from
the second onwards elements the series
would soon become world famous for
within the next hundred or two hundred
chapters the main character of goku
would change radically from a child of
earth to a man of the stars moving on
from his earth-based skirmishes to
increasingly devastating clashes with
the likes of vegeta frieza's cell and
majin buu with each clash more
fantastical than the last they created
what would ultimately become known as
power creep the idea of things having to
get bigger and bigger to the point that
narrative logic of power between
characters became unmanageable for many
people that's a sticking point and a
reason they can't enjoy much of the
material even extending as far as the
modern day content for others the line
is different and more focused on
narrative moments and there are numerous
spots where people might arbitrarily
point to as a shark jumping point of no
return for them anywhere from goku's
reveal as an alien to dragon ball gt in
all of its craziness and from there
naturally there's the numerous
continuations of the series in the
modern era through the likes of battle
of gods in 2013 and so on through to
dragon ball super's anime any one of
these places can no doubt play host to a
specific point in time where fans might
consider it a definitive drop-off point
in the series for them heck i'm sure
there are those of you who enjoyed the
beginning of dragon ball super but fell
off halfway through for your own
independent reasons these however are
all narrative moments though specific
points that were a breaking point for
people but what i'd like to argue and
what i think is most critical in
pinpointing the death of dragon ball is
beyond that it's external and it's a
very clear-cut change in the series and
that clear-cut change took place on
the 23rd of may
1995. on that day people across japan
flooded into their convenience stores
and local shonen jump outlets to witness
the conclusion to what was at the time
the most successful manga of all time
dragon ball chapter 519
now i'm sure many of you are scratching
your heads right now at this choice i
mean it's not like dragon ball doesn't
become more popular after 1995 gt may
not have been hugely successful but the
franchise still goes on to gain
worldwide acclaim but it's after this
point that i think the most considerable
differences occur a change external to
the story and one that i believe
influences why people have such
differences in experience and opinion
online and so this brings us to the most
interesting part of the video why is
this the point that dragon ball died for
a large population of people
today's video is brought to you by our
longtime partners over at manscape.com
they've been great supporters of this
channel for a while now and i've spoken
at length about their performance
package bundle in the past it really is
the best head to toe grooming kit i've
encountered and their lawnmower 4.0 is
the star of the package with its
wonderful led light and skin safe tech
the crop preserver ball deodorant is
also a pretty great part of the package
particularly in these hot months where
keeping cool and smelling great all day
is pretty damn important but what's also
essential is the follow through manscape
have released the new collection of
their anti-chafing high-performance
boxer briefs these bad boys feature a
fancy new dual pouch design a good old
bit of roomy space for your dangly bits
to breathe thanks to the perforated
performance fabric they're also now in
more than six colors combined there's a
simple all black pack or the classy grey
or pinstripe design heck there's even
this gold nugget craziness if you want
to go all out it's entirely up to you i
mean i'm not your mom whatever you
choose manscape offers the option to
select single units or save money with
their three pack options they're great
and if you go to manscape.com today and
use coupon code not mark 20 at checkout
you'll get 20 off plus free
international shipping that's not mark
20 at manscape.com your balls will thank
you
[Music]
as mentioned any one of the series
changes from its tone to its plot to its
art could have marked a legitimate
dropping off point for many but for me i
think dragon ball died the moment akira
toriyama stepped away from the driving
seat and again i know that sounds crazy
right toriyama has played a role in the
franchise for decades whether it's
little aspects like contributing designs
or even as far as pending entire scripts
for movies he's never really gone
anywhere but in spite of that the format
of his involvement has changed
dramatically and i'd argue that there
are repercussions here that affect that
very aspect that drew millions of fans
into dragon ball in the first place the
very aspect that brought the series
worldwide acclaim i am of course
speaking of the series action
dragon ball is famous for its grand epic
clashes of good versus evil young versus
old alien versus human and while those
aspects are still present in the modern
material
the action itself does not feel the same
i'm sure that's still a head scratcher
for many of you given the recent movies
and tv anime have produced some of the
finest looking action the series has
ever seen and again i agree but i think
it's important to understand that i
believe the action is simply different
rather than categorically better or
worse so what is different about the
action in a nutshell the battles lack a
narrative through line a sense of drama
within the fight itself during the
original run of dragon ball in the 80s
and 90s akira toriyama was forced to fly
by the seat of his pants as a writer
making up the story as he went along
sometimes week to week based on the
responses from his editor or audience
this had the unintentional benefit of
injecting narrative twists and snappy
pacing into each subsequent chapter that
was released and due to a large amount
of the runtime of the series comprising
itself of fighting he had to find a way
of weaving story beats and drama into
the dna of the fights themselves in
order to progress the story along
contrary to popular belief dragon ball
hasn't always been mindless fighting
it's always had a purpose with a
compelling narrative throughline that
hooked us all in within those short
chapters akira toriyama would seamlessly
blend narrative in action to both wow us
and propel the story forward resulting
in many breathtaking moments where they
would synergize and produce some of the
most emotionally resident action many of
us have ever come across gohan's super
saiyan 2 moment goku's kaioken heck even
just the basic goku and piccolo team up
against raditz these are all the result
of careful build-up and the fights that
follow them propel those plot points
forwards within the action itself if we
then look forwards to the battles of
resurrection f and dragon ball super
broly for example we can see a very
different format stories and films that
again begin by being front loaded
heavily with narrative that ultimately
takes a back seat once the action begins
and only resumes when it finally ends
and there's a very good reason the
modern material is like this and i'd
like to try and explain that by
analyzing a part of what many consider
to be one of the weakest arcs in
toriyama's original run the buu arc goku
vegeta and mr satan vs kid buu this
fight has so much happening developing
twisting and changing all occurring on
the fly as the gang tried to formulate a
plan for defeating buu once and for all
and due to the frantic manner by which
toriyama wrote it for those of you who
haven't read it chapter by chapter the
drama is heightened as plans fall apart
new ones are formulated and built upon
thereafter we've got vegeta's stalling
for goku to charge goku's charge not
working vegeta's realization that goku
was better than him and we've got goku
charging the spirit bomb all of this and
much more is contained squarely within
one final battle connecting things to
the past and introducing vital pieces of
the story as we progress through it and
due to effectively every 14 pages of
manga offering up a new key element of
the story when it came time for the
anime to be created using that material
that made for a series that felt
compelling and kinetic and this applies
to almost every major fight in the
original run there are b plots tensions
running in the background whether it's
waiting for goku to arrive in the saiyan
arc waiting for namic to explode waiting
for gohan to rise to the challenge or in
this case waiting for a last-ditch
spirit bomb to charge it's a
multi-faceted approach to action that
goes beyond simply punching one another
for 30 minutes this type of writing is
seldom found in modern dragon ball
material and is ultimately a result of
how akira toriyama contributes now if we
look at his scripts for resurrection f
broly and even the recent dragon ball
super superhero they are immensely
detailed in their build up toriyama put
so much love and care into the character
writing of those initial plot beats but
he very famously does not write the
action through his own admission in
interviews or by simply looking at the
scripts sold themselves we can see that
he writes things like and i quote and
now a big battle occurs with very vague
descriptions of his contents
[Applause]
i mean here's how resurrection f's
beloved group fight plays out on paper
quote an astounding battle begins this
scene is a major set piece of course i
just have to write the words so it's
pretty easy on my end sorry it'll
probably be rough on all of you
animators but please do your best and
that's it he contributes some gags like
krillin and jocko's banter but that's
all there is to it he goes to touch more
in depth for goku vs frieza by
requesting specifics like a beam
struggle or a specific set piece but
that's as far as he goes these days when
it comes to action the rest is left up
to the director and storyboard artist
for the film to conjure up how these
things flow together and while the
action can be astonishing particularly
in the case of dragon ball super broly
it's simply not their job to add
narrative on top of this then of course
you have the dragon ball super anime
series from 2015 to 2018 which was
effectively a million other writers
approaching and interpreting toriyama's
basic outline and even then you have the
complicated aspect of toriyama not
naturally writing the story as it comes
to him instead writing on prompts from
producers bring future trunks back what
about broly the authorial direction
toriyama once had in his weekly writing
simply isn't a thing anymore even the
dragon ball super manga in which
toriyama perhaps works the closest
having provided designs corrections
plotlines and general mentorship still
shows this phenomenon the full extent of
the writing is filtered through someone
else based on incomplete notes take
these points from the manga for example
unlike classic weekly chapter releases
toyotaro with dragon ball super's manga
releases once per month and within many
of those chapters we just get fighting
not dramatic fighting but just regular
old fighting that while many might find
entertaining for justifiable reasons are
specifically different to the type of
battle writing akira toriyama was forced
to employ back in the day with the
original series whether it be moro
granola or even the universe survival
arc i found myself waiting for the 45
plus page chapters of fighting to
conclude so we can get back to the
progression of the story when in reality
in the same way a mystery novel utilizes
the mystery aspect of the genre to
facilitate its narrative so too should
dragon ball utilize the battles and
fighting that they employ to facilitate
their stories not stall it and to put it
quite simply i think that's why these
modern dragon ball movies like
resurrection f dragon ball super broly
and dragon ball super super hero feel
and quite frankly are front loaded with
so much plot before the rest of the
narrative devolves into fighting and not
dramatic fighting either simply a battle
that exists due to build up but does not
evolve as it once would which let me be
clear here is totally fine to an extent
sometimes we just need a character to
throw another character into a mountain
sometimes we need that and far be it for
me to denounce the value of that one
moment goku had grinding on a blast from
kefla during the tournament of power
moments like those are memorable and
awesome and dragon ball should not do
without them the staff that creates
these moments from vague notes deserve
all the praise in the world and i truly
get a lot of joy out of them but this
isn't akira toriyama's dragon ball
anymore and that action isn't entwined
in the narrative as it once was the
format has changed and thus the feelings
we get during those battles the tension
and the drama are significantly
different it's now dragon ball by
committee a product that still has a lot
of value and what i'm sure we've all
found moments that speak to us but it's
those differences that create for many
of us a crushing realization that things
aren't going to be the same again and
that for us
may 23rd 1995
was the day dragon ball
died
[Music]
you